it's my pleasure to introduce uh your
local
depending on where you are nikhil
srivatsava from berkeley
and uh again if you're joining in uh
only this afternoon
uh we made all the participants into
panelists
so please try to mute during the talk
but if you
have a question feel free to unmute
yourself
and ask a question you can also pose
questions in q a and i'll try to keep an
eye on that
uh nikhil is going to talk about
gaussian regularization of the pseudo
spectrum
please go ahead nikki great well thanks
a lot prasad and thanks to the
organizers for
inviting me so um this is joint work
with jess banks jorge
garza vargas archit kulkarni and shatuki
mukherjee
who are students at uc berkeley well
earthship graduated
and the talk is about okay
it has a probabilistic component which
is about gaussian regularization of the
pseudo spectrum so i'll tell you what
all of that means and
in large part one of the goals of this
talk is to be an introduction to
pseudospectra which is something people
know
well in random matrix there but maybe
not as much in computer science
and then the second part of the talk
i'll talk about a application to
numerical linear algebra
okay so part one so uh and please stop
me if you have any questions so the
proofs
that i'm going to present are very
simple they're among the shortest proofs
you know that i've ever talked about so
i hope that you can understand all the
details and please stop me if you have
questions
okay so um so the talk is about
diagonalization okay so what is that so
um
so a matrix a complex square matrix is
diagonalizable if it's similar to a
diagonal matrix
so you can write it a as v dv inverse
where v is invertible and d is diagonal
and if you do this then v the columns of
v contain the right
eigenvectors of a and then the diagonal
entries contain the eigenvalues which
are some complex numbers
so uh here's a matrix uh that's
diagonalizable
s so this is a symmetric matrix so
okay it's hermitian it's equal to its
adjoint and as a result it's actually
orthogonally diagonalizable so uh
the i there's an orthonormal eigen basis
eigenvectors and you can plot them like
this
uh here's another matrix so t
t is similar to s so it's it's s times
a diagonal similarity where the entries
in the similarity are exponentially
increasing
okay so t you know looks superficially
quite similar to s except that it's not
hermitian
and because it's similar it has the same
eigenvalues but its eigenvectors are now
given by cv and they're highly
non-orthogonal
okay so this is one of the key
differences between hermitian and
non-hermitian matrices
that the eigenvectors in this case are
linearly independent but
not orthogonal anymore
and then uh so this is also
diagonalizable and then here's a matrix
that's not diagonalizable
the jordan block so
okay this this only has one eigenvector
it does not even have
a basis of linearly independent
eigenvectors
so the question i want to study in this
talk is
well is related to quantitative
diagonalizability
so i want to measure how diagonalizable
a matrix is
so one there are many ways to do that
which we'll see in the talk but one
natural one is to look at the
eigenvector condition number
okay so let kappa e of a be the
condition number of the eigenvector
matrix of a
so you notice that okay so the
eigenvectors don't come with a canonical
scaling so let's take this to be the
minimum of the condition number over all
scalings of the eigenvectors
okay so that's the eigenvector condition
number of a
and that's a quantitative measure of how
linearly independent the eigenvectors
are so in our three examples here we can
calculate this parameter so
in the first example the eigenvector
condition number is one because the
eigenvectors are
the eigenvector matrix is orthogonal
in the second example the eigenvector
condition number is actually 2 to the n
minus 1. it's just the condition number
of the c that we
hit the eigenvectors with okay so it's
that reflects the fact that these are
somehow this is less diagonalizable
and then okay in the case of the jordan
block you don't even have a basis of
eigenvectors so you can think of that as
saying that the eigenvector condition
number is infinity so all the
eigenvectors collapse into one vector
so okay so what what else do we know
well
every matrix is a limit of
diagonalizable matrices so
diagonalizable matrices are dense
but the question i want to study is this
quantitative question
which is given a particular matrix
can you find a nearby matrix that is
well diagonalizable
okay so specifically given a matrix and
some parameter delta
can i find a perturbation of size delta
such that the perturbed matrix has a
small eigenvector condition number so
that's what i mean by well
diagonalizable
okay and this is a quantitative version
of this
fact that you can approximate any matrix
by a
by a sequence of diagonalizable matrices
now i'm asking
how diagonalizable okay
so this picture here is sort of a
cartoon this red curve is
some i guess uh you know manifold of uh
non-diagonalizable matrices and what i'm
asking is suppose i give you some a that
may or may not be diagonalizable
i want to find an e so that a plus c has
a small eigenvector condition number
okay so that's a sort of a pretty
basic linear algebra question but the
motivation for asking this question
actually came from
numerical linear algebra and here's
where it came from
historically so here's a problem that
comes up in numerical computation
you have a matrix a which may not be
hermitian
and you want to compute some analytic
function analytic in a neighborhood of
the spectrum
of that matrix so for example e to the z
that's a nice one or maybe you want to
compute some fractional power
so what's uh you know what does this
mean right
so what is what does f of a even mean
well
what it means is that you if the matrix
is diagonalizable it means that you
diagonalize the matrix and apply the
function to the spectrum directly
so using this definition i have that f
of a is equal to v
times f of dv inverse if a is
diagonalizable
well this gives me some naive algorithm
for doing this
but this algorithm is is actually not a
good algorithm in a lot of cases so
for example consider this topless matrix
t that i looked at
in the first slide uh let's take n
equals 100 so then it's that's not a
very big matrix um
its eigenvector condition number is 10
to the 30.
so if you try to diagonalize this matrix
you're going to end up
trying to invert a matrix whose
condition number is 10 to the 30
and you're not going to succeed in doing
that like that's
way bigger than machine precision you're
going to get some garbage
so so what what do you do if you want to
compute
uh you know a function of such a matrix
so one empirical observation uh made by
brian davies but this experiment was
done by mark embry as the following
if you take this matrix and now you add
a gaussian perturbation to it
then the eigenvector condition number of
the perturbed matrix
is much smaller as indicated in this
plot so
on the x-axis you have the norm of the
perturbation that you're adding
and on the y-axis you have the
eigenvector condition number of the
perturbed matrix
and what's seen is that well roughly
speaking if you add a perturbation
of norm 10 to the minus 5 your
eigenvector condition number went down
to 10 to the 5
which is very manageable and roughly
speaking it appears to be some kind of
linear relationship
so the empirical phenomenon here is that
well this matrix
has a terrible eigenvector condition
number but it's very close to matrix
a matrix with much better eigenvector
condition number
so so
this led davies to propose the following
scheme for
computing a matrix of a function of a
not of a matrix
the idea is well don't compute f of a
compute f of a
a plus e for some tiny e
okay so for example let's say you want
to compute the square root of a matrix
so here's a matlab code that's proposed
in this paper
well don't just compute the square root
of a first generate
a random normal a random gaussian matrix
times some small
delta then diagonalize the perturbed
matrix
and output uh you know the naive
square root of that matrix okay so
diagonalize the perturbed matrix
if that has a small eigenvector
condition number then maybe you should
be able to do that
and then output this s
and the nice thing is that this code
actually does better than matlab square
root command
on various non-hermitian matrices so
these are some experiments
carried out by embry where if you
naively just run matlab square root you
start getting garbage
after matrices of size maybe 40 but if
you apply this regularizing perturbation
before and then compute the square root
of that well the
the nice thing is that what you get
actually turns out to be much closer to
the square of the original matrix
okay so adding this random perturbation
regularizes the computation
so this led davies to ask this question
that
well what is the dependence of this
kappa e on this delta
and he proved the following theorem so
he proved that given any matrix
uh and some parameter delta there's a
perturbation of norm
delta okay delta uh the matrix is the
original matrix has no one so there's a
perturbation of norm
at most delta so that when you add this
when you perturb a by this
e this perturbation e then the new
eigenvector condition number
is at most roughly one over square delta
to the n
okay so that's what he was able to prove
now that's not
quite uh you know predicting what we saw
in the experiment right so in the
experiment it looked like the
eigenvector condition number
was decaying somewhat linearly in the
size of the perturbation
whereas this theorem says it decays that
all this theorem proves is that it's at
most exponential and one over the size
so in particular this theorem is
actually not that useful for computation
because you said delta would be let's
say a half you still get two to the n
out of this but davies made this
conjecture that
really the right dependence should be
inverse linear so for every matrix a
the conjecture is that for every matrix
a there exists a perturbation e
so that the eigenvector condition number
of the perturbed matrix
is some function of n over delta
and this would be useful in the
application i just mentioned
and uh he proved the conjecture for n
equals three well because you know the
theorem above for n equals 3 is
actually gives this and he proved it in
the special case of a equal to a jordan
block
but it couldn't prove the theorem in
general
so any questions about conjecture
uh i mean the is the conjecture is that
it exists or the conjectures that that
this high probability
any other
okay in the conjecture i guess there is
no
probability right there's no probability
so i'm going to solve the conjecture by
proving that it's
with probability but the original
conjecture is just about existence
okay so the the first theorem i want to
talk about is that
the conjecture is true so the theorem is
that uh
yes this is true and the dependence is
4n to the 3 halves over delta for every
a there exists a perturbation e of
norm delta so that this is true
uh so in particular it means if you set
the perturbation to one over poly n it
means every matrix has a one over poly
and size perturbation with
eigenvector condition number poly n
um and as anticipated by many people
this is you know such as galena's
question right now this is implied by a
probabilistic result
but the probabilistic result is actually
about a different
related quality called the eigenvalue
condition number
okay so any questions about the
statement of the theorem before i
move to that
i guess do you expect it to be tight
uh you mean this bound uh so we proved
that the dependence on delta is tight
uh we don't know about the dependence on
n
thanks uh do you know there if there
should be a dependence on them like is
it
so in fact there's a 1989 conjecture
from operator theory
that there should be no dependence on it
possibly at the cost of some other
dependence
may i ask if you could remind what is
the dependence that giants involved got
in the real version
was it different that who excuse me well
and uh symbol i might be
uh yeah i'll talk about that later yeah
yeah so that's a
sort of follow-up of this result i'll
talk about it later
okay
[Music]
they got almost the same thing with the
log delta but
i see okay so okay so what is a
condition number of eigenvalues
so let me define it so suppose you have
a diagonalizable matrix a
with distinct eigenvalues i'm only going
to define it for distinct eigenvalues
and now i'm going to write its spectral
decomposition additively as summation
lambda i v i w i star so w
i star the left eigenvectors v are the
right eigenvectors they're normalized to
have w i star vi equals one
so if you look at these matrices v and v
inverse the w i star of the rows of v
inverse
so the eigenvalue condition number of
the eigenvalue lambda i
is the norm of wi times the norm of vi
okay so these are vectors that are not
unit vectors they're normalized to have
inner product
equal to one that's what it means to
have v times v inverse equal to one
but for non-hermitian matrix uh
uh you know their norms could be way way
bigger when you make this normalization
so this
this eigenvalue value condition number
is one over the cosine of the angle
between the left and right eigenvectors
so in the hermitian case these numbers
are all equal to one because the left
and right eigenvectors are the same
but as you become more and more
degenerate this blows up
so why is this called the eigenvalue
condition number so it turns out this is
the number that controls the speed of
perturbation
of any particular eigenvalue when you
add it
when you add it when you add a tiny
perturbation so if you look at a plus e
and you look at lambda i some eigenvalue
well this is saying that if you apply a
tiny perturbation
then the protruded eigenvalue is the
size of the perturbation times this
eigenvalue condition number so this
measures the sensitivity of a particular
eigenvalue
to perturbations okay and this is all
well defined because eigenvalues are
simple
[Music]
so this is now another measure
of quantitative diagonalizability right
so small eigenvalue condition numbers
means
uh somehow strongly diagonalizable
that's what i'm going to take it to mean
but
in particular it means that the spectrum
is stable
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry so so what's
written here is
sort of in the worst case oh okay
yeah sorry so what's written here you're
right you can find a perturbation that
doesn't affect lambda at all just move
along some other eigen direction
uh so you're right i should say that uh
you know the size of the perturbation is
upper bounded by this quantity
so so would the direction of this bad
perturbation i guess be
the iwi star or uh
the direction of this bad perturbation
uh yeah that's the worst case so there's
a worst case direction which would be in
that rank one
uh well actually no uh no no so if you
take e equal to v i
at w i star then
um i mean normalized this way the norm
of e
itself is already very big so so
actually if you
so actually the bad direction is not
actually v i w i star
if you add it it's not
wouldn't you just scale the eigenvalue
uh okay so if you just
if you just move by a it's okay so i'm
thinking of this kappa lambda
as big being a very big number so if you
just
add a multiple of a then the eigenvalue
is just going to if you look at a
plus delta a let's say right the
eigenvalue is just gonna
if i is n it would be just the worst
direction right so i guess but if it's
not then
i mean if it's the biggest eigenvalues
and well the eigenvalues are complex so
i'm not
necessarily assuming they're ordered in
okay
in any way um the
okay fine so if you take the derivative
of lambda i
let me just say if you take the
derivative of uh
the directional derivative of lambda i
in the direction e
it's equal to the quadratic form uh w
star e v okay
and these w w star and v so the point of
this is
what this is saying is that if w star
and v have big norm
then this uh then this perturbation is
large
oh i'm sorry okay now i see what nick is
saying you're right so if you want to
maximize that
over let's say matrices of unit norm
you yeah i guess you would i guess you
would take
uh you would take w
v star
okay thanks yeah sorry to be ready no no
sorry i misunderstood the question
yeah um okay
so uh so this is related to the
eigenvector condition number in the
following way
um it's uh
it's polynomially controlled on both
sides by the
uh the eigenvalue eigenvector condition
number is polynomially controlled by the
largest eigenvalue condition number
and some uh you know root n times the
sum of its squares so up to
polynomial factors these quantities are
relatable
for any matrix is a deterministic
statement
okay so now uh so
let me mention now theorem b which
implies theorem a
this is a probabilistic theorem so
suppose a is a matrix of bounded norm
and let's take g to have iid complex
standard gaussian entries
then with probability 1 the eigenvalues
of a plus gamma g are
distinct so gamma's some positive
parameter
and call these eigenvalues lambda 1
through lambda n
and if you a complex standard gaussian
means it's a gaussian in the complex
plane where the real and imaginary parts
have
variance one-half so okay then the
theorem says if you fix
any open ball b in the complex plane so
in this picture i fixed this
yellow disk then you know if you look at
the average of the sum of squares of the
eigenvalue condition
numbers of the eigenvalues that land in
that disk
that's bounded by n over gamma squared
times the area of the disk
okay so the eigenvalues are random
right so the sum is over a random subset
of the eigenvalues
so you fix b in advance and then over
over
only the eigenvalues that land and b the
sum of squares of the eigenvalue
condition numbers is bounded as such and
the right hand side
you can see is uh you know depends in
some very nice way on
n and on the size of the perturbation
okay so uh
this theorem uh you can you can compare
this to existing
theorems in the random matrix theory
literature so uh
people have studied in great detail the
case of a equals zero so what happens if
you just have a pure
complex gaussian matrix and
in that case they're very precise
asymptotics for the joint
you know limiting distribution of these
eigenvalue condition numbers
due to starting with chakra and melee
again most recently due to burgard duvac
and fedorov
and also in the mathematical physics
literature
people have studied in great detail the
case when a is a topless matrix
and again they've proved some various
precise limit laws for the distribution
of these
eigenvalue condition numbers
in contrast what we prove is uh
much coarser it's just an upper bound on
the expectation
but it's true for any a and it's totally
non-asymptotic
and i should mention that some of these
random matrix results imply that this
theorem is sharp
and its dependence on n and its
dependence on gamma it's actually sharp
in the case a equals zero
so any questions about the statement of
theorem b
so n in prince in particular cannot be
replaced by
say how many lambdas land inside me
um okay so i i should be precise about
the quantifier
so it's sharp in the sense that if you
fix
for there's a particular b for which the
dependence on n is sharp
i don't know if uh if you can replace n
by the number of eigenvalues
okay so uh so how does this imply
theorem a well it implies crma in a
pretty straightforward way
so what's the proof of theorem
i'm given a matrix a i need to find this
perturbation e
i'm going to take e to be gamma times g
where g is a complex gaussian matrix and
let's assume gamma is less than 1 over
square root n
that's the right normalization because
the norm of g is
2 square root n with high at most 2
squared n with high probability
plus little over 1. so then some
standard random matrix theory results
tell us that the norm of a plus gamma g
is less than 4 with very high
probability
okay a is normalized to have normal less
than 1.
so then with very high probability
actually all the eigenvalues will lie in
a disk of radius 4.
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
invoke theorem b with a disk of radius 4
in the complex plane
so what does c and b say well just by
markov it says that with constant
probability
the sum of squares of the eigenvalue
condition numbers of the eigenvalues in
that disk
are bounded by n over gamma squared
times the area which is some constant
so now if i take that and multiply by n
and take the square root that says that
that quantity is bounded by n
over gamma right so i have n times n
over gamma squared square root of the
whole thing is n over gamma
so now i take a union bound so i have
with constant probability this holds
but as i said all the eigenvalues land
on the disk so the sum over
eigenvalues and b is the sum of all
eigenvalues
and you know i showed you earlier that
this is
an upper bound on the eigenvector
condition number
so so then that's it right because now
the size of the perturbation
is gamma times the norm of g which is
gamma times square root n
and so in terms of the size of the
perturbation the eigenvector condition
number i get is n to the three halves
over delta which was
what was advertised
okay can i ask a question
yep so for theorem b the upper bound
does not depend on location of the
ball right but if the ball is very far
away from origin you would expect
the number of eigenvalues smaller there
so is there like
yeah is there some intuition about bond
or why is it looking like well
so i mean okay so one intuition related
to the theorem is
that unstable eigenvalues will tend to
move randomly okay so let's say i choose
a tiny ball around an eigenvalue
right so so you know
let's say i have fixed a i have one
eigenvalue and i choose a tiny ball
around it so then the volume of that b
will be very tiny right
so the right hand side will be tiny if
that eigenvalue is unstable what this
theorem is saying is that
most likely it's going to leave the ball
does that make sense so if so unstable
eigenvalues cannot be concentrated in a
small region of the complex plane that's
what the theorem is saying after
applying the random perturbation
okay but but you're right you have to
apply the theorem judiciously if you
choose a ball that's
far away from the spectrum the left-hand
side should be zero
and you'll get some bound on the
right-hand side so you have to choose b
somehow judiciously uh
you know to if i mean if you want to
get a meaningful conclusion okay is
there also a
high probability analog of the theorem
uh no so this stuff
this distribution is known to be heavy
tailed so it actually doesn't even have
finite second movement
so there's no high probability analog
okay so in particular that means that
this markov that i did in this little
argument cannot really be
improved
okay um so so now let's prove theorem b
any more questions about theorem b
so what i've achieved so far is i've
gone from the eigenvector condition
number
which was somewhat intimidating quantity
involving all the eigenvectors
to studying eigenvalue condition numbers
which are somewhat more local quantities
and now i'll show how to analyze that
using the notion of pseudospectrum
okay so uh so what is the pseudo
spectrum so the pseudo spectrum of a
matrix
is a set in the complex plane
parameterized by a parameter epsilon
so the epsilon pseudo spectrum of a
matrix m
is the set of points in the complex
plane where the resolvent
which is z minus m inverse has operator
norm bigger than one over epsilon
okay so this is a picture of some matrix
with three eigenvalues
uh and i i guess it's a plot of the norm
of the resolvent
uh and uh the peaks so the poles of this
function are the eigenvalues right so
the resolvent has poles at the
eigenvalues and the pseudospectrum is
asking well what are the level sets of
that function
so as you make epsilon smaller these
sets become smaller
because it's a small it's a level set of
the resolvent being larger
so there's a beautiful book that i
highly recommend about this um
but uh okay what do these sets look like
well for normal matrices it's very
straightforward
to see that the pseudospectra are just
disks of radius epsilon around the
spectrum
so if m is normal or hermitian
then the pseudospectrum is just you know
disc of radius epsilon around the
spectrum
but for non-normal matrices it can look
a lot more interesting so this is a
picture of the pseudospectrum of some
non-normal matrix
now what does this have to do with
diagonalizability and spectral stability
well there are these two alternate
characterizations of the pseudo spectrum
so this this is equal to two other sets
so the first is a set of points z where
the least singular value of z minus n is
less than epsilon this is a triviality
this is just because
the norm of z minus m inverse is equal
to one over the least singular value
of z minus x so it's a set of shifts
z so that the shifted matrix has a
smaller singular value
and then a slightly less obvious
equality is that it's the union of the
spectra
of all perturbations of a of norm less
than epsilon so this is a
very nice exercise which i encourage you
to do if you want to get a feel for this
and this is why it's a very relevant
quantity for spectral stability it's
the set of all possible eigenvalues you
can get by perturbing the matrix
m by a matrix of norm epsilon
so that's a pseudo spectrum so let's
look at our three examples in terms of
pseudospectrum the pseudo the first
matrix is remission the pseudospectrum
is literally just
a disc of radius epsilon around
the spectrum boring
if you look at t the pseudo spectrum is
a lot more interesting so the black dots
are the eigenvalues
and these curves are the level curves of
this function the norm of the resolvent
for epsilon i believe going down from
10 to the minus 1 to 10 to the minus 16.
so what you see
so the outermost curve is the 10 to the
minus 1 pseudospectrum so if you had a
perturbation of size at 10th the
eigenvalues can travel that far
and notice that that's a lot bigger than
a tenth
but even more stark is look at the inner
pseudo spectra right so the innermost
oval or whatever shape that is is a 10
to the minus 16 pseudo spectrum
so you're adding perturbation of size 10
to the minus 16 to the matrix
yet the eigenvalues can move
macroscopically far away
so this is you know this really is what
we mean by spectral instability
that the spectrum moves a lot when you
add a tiny perturbation
and then finally for the jordan block if
you actually plot the pseudo spectrum
you get some even bigger disks
okay so
so the pseudo spectrum is now a third
notion of
spectral stability that i'm going to
relate to my previous two notions
so the bauerfect theorem says that the
pseudo spectrum
of a matrix is contained in disks of
radius at most the eigenvector condition
number around the eigenvalues
so this means if you have small
eigenvector condition number you have
small pseudo spectrum
and similarly if you have small
if you have small eigenvalue condition
numbers so these kappa lambda i
then the pseudo spectrum is contained in
disks of radius
about kappa lambda i epsilon
times the is centered at the is
eigenvalue
in the regime of small very small
perturbation epsilon okay
so high level if you control the
previous any of either of the previous
two quantities that implies that the
pseudospectrum is small
so any questions about the definition of
pseudospectrum or any of these
equivalences
okay so i've introduced three maybe a
question of
uh computability since mentioned
numerous algebra how easy is it to work
with
pseudo spectrum how easy is it to
compute i don't know off the top of my
head
there are algorithms they're matlab
packages that do it i don't know if
people computer scientists have
seriously studied the complexity of
doing it
thanks
okay so um
okay so so so now with this new concept
in hand let me prove theorem b
so the proof of theorem b has four steps
so step one is to relate the sum of
squares of the eigenvalue
condition numbers to a limiting area of
the pseudo spectrum
okay so here's lemma one it says if you
have a matrix is a deterministic lemma
about every matrix if you have a
square matrix with distinct eigenvalues
m and you have some open set b
then the sum of squares of the
eigenvalue condition numbers
of the eigenvalues in that set this is
equal to the
limiting area of the epsilon pseudo
spectrum
restricted to that set as divided by
epsilon squared
as epsilon goes to zero okay so i'm
writing this as a scaling limit of the
area of the pseudo spectrum
okay so this is not a new lemma this is
uh
must be known for decades here's uh
but what it says is that there's a
converse to the fact that i wrote on the
previous slide
so in the previous slide i wrote that
the epsilon pseudospectrum is contained
in disks of radius
kappa lambda i times epsilon around the
eigenvalues lambda i
well if that was actually sharp well
then the area
what would be the area of the pseudo
spectrum it would just be
you know pi times kappa lambda i squared
times epsilon squared
the sum of those quantities so if you
divide by epsilon squared you would get
the quantity on the left-hand side
so this is seen as a converse to the
fact that i proved in the
previous that i stated in the previous
slide
and the proof is very straightforward
you just take the resolvent you
take the spectral expansion of the
resolver and let's suppose you have some
number z that's close to some eigenvalue
let's say lambda 3.
well as you approach the eigenvalue uh
all the other terms become are bounded
right the only one term is blowing up
the one corresponding to the eigenvalue
lambda 3.
so you have this v 3u w3 star that's a
spectral projector onto that subspace
divided by z minus lambda 3 plus
something that's bounded as z approaches
lambda 3.
so then that's it right now now you just
see it so
in the regime of very small epsilon the
resolvent being bigger than one over
epsilon
implies that for some eigenvalue this
term has to be bigger than one over
epsilon
and that's the same thing as saying that
z is within distance
uh the norm of the spectral projector
times epsilon of some eigenvalue but
that's just the norm of the spectral
projector is just the eigenvalue
condition number
okay so this is like a one line proof
basically
when you go near an eigenvalue the
matrix becomes rank one and for rank one
matrices this is kind of obvious
okay so any questions about this lemma
so what i'm doing is i'm passing from
the eigenvalue condition numbers to area
of the pseudo spectrum
and okay why not for fun just throwing
limb in fear
that'll be useful later
okay so now my goal becomes to control
the area of the pseudospectrum
so how would i do that well the main
tool i need to do this is
comes from smooth analysis uh
and it's it's the following the starting
point of the following theorem of
sunker's field
and tang which says if you take any real
n by n matrix and you add a gaussian
with real
independent with id real standard
gaussian entries
then the probability that the least
singular value of
m plus gamma g so that's why it's a
smooth analysis you perturb
the fixed matrix by this random matrix
the probability that that has least
singular value less than epsilon
is some constant times squared n times
epsilon over gamma
okay so it makes sense that this bound
should get worse as gamma gets smaller
if you take a bigger perturbation you
expect more regularization
um and the you know maybe
important so the important feature of
this bound is that this decays
as the probability that the least single
value is less than epsilon decays as
epsilon
so what's the proof of this let me prove
this in n equals one
okay so for n equals one m is a number
gamma g is a number the probability the
least singular value is just the
magnitude of the number
the probability that m plus gamma g is
less than epsilon so epsilon is
some fixed num some fixed parameter this
is just equal to the probability that
the standard gaussian g
is within distance epsilon over gamma of
minus
m over gamma right that's just
literally what it is and then by some
very standard anti-concentration this is
at most m of epsilon over gamma
the gaussian you know the most mass it
puts is
on the window near zero and you just get
that it's this
so of course the proof for matrices is
more complicated and
at a high level they handle this using
orthogonal invariance but
this is the thing i want to emphasize
about the proof
is that the dependence on epsilon comes
from this one-dimensional fact about
anti-concentration of real gaussians
and what is known about the reverse
inequality
uh well it's when m is zero the reverse
inequality
no but i mean for various m um
i i don't i don't know
i i mean is there any result
i mean so i think there are results i
don't know if there's a crisp
conjectured lower bound in terms of some
function of m
uh i think vishesh might know more about
this than i do or maybe it's go authors
but i don't think there's a very crisp
characterization of what how this bound
depends on it
okay so uh so one
so the the second step in the proof is
not this
but it's it's a variation of this it's
well what if you take a matrix and add a
complex gaussian
okay so this is lambda 2. so you take
any complex matrix and add a
matrix with complex iit gaussian entries
so then the claim is that the
probability that the least singular
value is less than epsilon
decays as epsilon squared over gamma
squared okay so everything gets squared
now what's the proof for n equals one
well the same
you know it's the probability that a
complex gaussian is close to some fixed
number
but now this is the whole point that the
complex gaussian is a two-dimensional
object
so the probability that it's close to
any point in the complex plane the case
is the square
of the distance to that point so you get
epsilon squared over gamma squared
and so okay the way we actually prove
the lemma for matrices is we use a
coupling theorem of snare
to reduce to the case of a equals 0 and
then the case a 0 is exactly solved by
eight women in the 80s
okay so the thing i want to emphasize is
you go from epsilon to epsilon squared
when you take a complex gaussian
okay that's step two now step three is
to use this to control the area of the
pseudospectrum in a sort of
obvious way so lemma 2 says that if you
take any matrix m and
subtract gamma g from it the probability
that at least singular value is less
than epsilon decays as epsilon squared
over gamma squared
so now let's apply this to a shift of my
input matrix a so remember in the
background there's this input matrix a
that's given to me
so let's fix some epsilon fix some
complex number z
and look at z minus a the shifted matrix
well the theorem says that the
probability of the least singular value
of z minus a minus gamma
g is less than epsilon is upper bounded
by this
quantity epsilon squared over gamma
squared
but that's literally the probability
that z is in the epsilon pseudo spectrum
right that's the definition of pseudo
spectrum
so what i actually have shown is that
for every complex number
and every epsilon the probability that
that number as it falls in the epsilon
pseudo spectrum
has this kind of decay
okay but that's very nice right because
if you fix some ball b
well what's the expected area of the
pseudo spectrum restricted to that ball
well it's just an
expectation of an integral of an
indicator random variable
right so i just integrate over z in the
ball what's the
that z is in the pseudo spectrum but now
i can do fubini right so i move the
expectation inside
i just need to integrate this
probability that a fixed z is in this
epsilon zero spectrum
but now i have this like worst case
bound on this
right i just have that for every z it's
at most n epsilon squared over gamma
squared
so quite easily just by this fubini
argument i've computed the expected area
of the pseudo spectrum
and i've upper bounded it by some nice
function times epsilon squared
so that's the third step in the proof so
any questions about this step
okay and then the fourth step of the
proof
is uh so let's call this lemma three for
every ball the expected area is small
and then lemma four let to be very
pedantic let's define a non-negative
function
which is the scaled area of the epsilon
pseudo spectrum by epsilon squared
and lemma 3 shows that the lim info of
the expectation of this is bounded by n
over
gamma squared right so i bounded the
expected area
so i have that the limit of the expected
area is bounded by n over gamma squared
but then by fattu's lama that means that
the expected limit
is bounded by an organ squared
but now what was lemma one well the
expected limit is the sum of squares of
the eigenvalue condition numbers times
pi
so that's the proof that's all proof
it's very simple
so to summarize the proof in one slide
this is the proof the sum of squares of
the expected eigenvalue condition
numbers is an
expected scaled limit of the pseudo
spectrum area
which is bounded by the limit of the
expected pseudospectral area
which by fubini can be controlled by
just controlling this one tail
probability of a fixed point being in
the epsilon zero spectrum
which i may be able to produce
okay so it basically involves changing
order of limit and summation three times
so that's the proof of the theorem and
this is a picture explaining the
mechanism behind the result so on the
left hand side i have a matrix a
which is quite spectrally unstable it's
actually a topless matrix with
all eigenvalues at zero and as you can
see it's epsilon pseudos it's
these are various pseudo-spectral
contours these are quite large the
pseudo spectrum is big
and if you add a tiny gaussian
perturbation to it what you get is a
picture on the right
so the eigen values move a lot but the
new pseudo spectrum
as a set is very is much smaller right
these new the green circles became tiny
now
so that's uh that's it that's the proof
of theorem b so the the high level idea
is that
it's important to use three of these
notions of spectral stability the
eigenvalue vector condition number the
eigenvalue condition numbers and the
pseudo spectrum
and by combining these in some
appropriate way you can go from a very
global quantity such as kappa e
to very local quantities namely singular
values of shifts
which then you can bound using
properties of this complex gaussian
okay so there's one further development
in this which is
something somebody asked about which is
we really heavily used that the gaussian
is complex in this right
so we used it because you really needed
the pseudospectral area to decay as
epsilon squared
so what happens for real perturbations
right so if you if you if you take a
matrix and add a real perturbation
then um actually the tailbone you get is
only order epsilon it's not epsilon
squared
so you cannot do this argument for real
perturbations
okay the limit will simply blow up
and so uh it was a mystery for
a little while you know whether this can
work for real perturbations
but then it turns out there's uh there's
actually an important phenomenon that
causes this to also work for real
perturbations so what we can show
is that uh while it's true that this
singular value decay is order epsilon
for real z
if you have a if you have a real
gaussian matrix g
and a complex number z okay
then uh then the the pro the
probability of the least singular value
of z minus a minus gamma g
is less than epsilon this decays at
epsilon squared over the imaginary part
of z
okay so this is inspired by a theorem
that proven the thesis of stephen gur
where he proved this plus some additive
term
depending on which doesn't depend on
epsilon which was a problem for us but
there's this very interesting phenomenon
which is if you look at the resolvent
of a real random matrix a real
gaussian random matrix not centered if
you look at it at complex numbers you
still get this epsilon squared tail
decay
so using this by proving splitting into
real and imaginary eigenvalues
we were able to prove a slightly weaker
theorem as theorem a
which is that even for for any g with
absolute continuous real independent
entries
uh the eigenvector condition number is
bounded by some poly n over gamma to the
c
and we were able to get three halves so
not one
uh but independently jan saw and sony
proved a stronger result where they're
able to get one plus little of one
so the conceptual point is that this
phenomenon even though the proof
used complex gaussians there's a way to
do the proof for much more general
perturbations
this proof is much more involved but the
phenomenon continues to hold
okay so i spent more time on that than i
wanted so let me briefly talk about
numerical linear algebra for five
minutes
so there's actually still a loose end in
this story
right so in the beginning of the talk i
told you that
this was my proposal for computing the
square root which is you give me a
matrix a
i perturb it by random matrix and i
diagonalize the perturbed matrix
and then i you know take the square root
of that but how do you actually
diagonalize a matrix
so this leads to this algorithmic
question of approximate diagonalization
which is a well-defined sort of
algorithm algorithmic question
which is given a complex matrix how do
you find its eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
so there are many ways of making this
formal and the one that's standard in
numerical analysis
which i'll also sort of argue is a good
one in a moment
is the following given a matrix a and
some error parameter epsilon
how do i find some matrices v naught and
d naught
so that a minus v naught d naught v
naught inverse is
has norm less than epsilon
okay so conceptually what this is saying
is given an a
i don't want to compute approximations
of the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a
what i want to do is exactly compute the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues of a nearby
matrix a naught
so this is called backward error and
this is a standard notion of numerical
analysis
and notice that some notion of error is
necessary right you cannot compute
eigenvalues
or eigenvectors of a matrix exactly on a
computer
it's not possible okay so that's the
the problem and uh okay what's the
justification for this backward error
model well there are two possible
ways you could say this is reasonable
one is a very practical answer
is that if you're actually doing
something on a computer but
certainly in scientific computing if
something came from a scientific problem
you never know the exact the matrix
exactly
in that setting and anyway the numbers
are stored in floating point
so you might as well assume there's some
tiny error and so
you know finding you know finding a
exact answer to a nearby problem is
somehow as good as you can hope for
but there's also sort of a deeper
mathematical rationale for backward
error analysis which i think is quite
beautiful which is that well
any stable quantity of any stable
feature of a
let's say you want to compute some
invariant subspace corresponding to a
group of eigenvalues
or let's say you want to compute an
eigenvector well
if that quantity is stable stable means
doesn't change drastically under
perturbations well it's not going to
change much
when you pass to a naught right
so for any stable quantity this is
perfectly fine
that the the eigenvectors of a naught
that you get are going to be very close
to the eigenvectors of a anyway
okay so that's backward error and
you know just to give an example of this
rationale
um if you wanted to get a forward error
estimate
given such a backward error solution the
way you would do it is the following
so here's a little theorem suppose you
have
two matrices a and a naught whose
operator norm is absol
differences at most epsilon then
uh the distance between the eigen
decompositions
is bounded by epsilon times this k of a
which is a new
condition number i'm defining which is
equal to the eigenvector condition
number of a divided by the minimum
eigenvalue gap of a
okay so this is in particular this is
saying that if you give me a matrix with
well-spaced eigenvalues and
well-conditioned eigenvectors
then computing the eigen decomposition
of a nearby matrix
will give something close to the
identity composition of the original
matrix so you can pass from backward
error to forward error
by you know arguments like this
okay so this is the question so any
questions about the question
okay so this is an algorithmic question
and surprisingly little was known about
this question
so this is a quite fundamental question
um and as far as i can tell there are
only two
rigorous results about this until
recently
so the first result is due to geniusei
from 1994
and what he proved is that you can solve
this problem in polynomial time
a polynomial number of bit operations
okay so you give me some rational matrix
a then in time polynomial and the length
of the input
i can produce such a v naught and d
naught
in time polynomial and n uh and log of
epsilon and the num
i need to do this i need to do
arithmetic with numbers of size
polynomial and n
and log one over epsilon and these
polynomials are quite large i think the
final running time was n to the 12.
so for a while it was an open question
about well how
you know is there an algorithm that
solves this eigen problem
using a small amount of precision like
ideally poly logarithmic
okay so on an actual computer you don't
use polynomial n bits of precision
so that's called a numerically stable
algorithm and this this was open for
i guess several decades and it was
solved
in the in uh at least in the polynomial
time sense by armantano beltran berger
circle current job
in 2015 and they proved that there's an
algorithm that solves this problem in
time
n to the 10 over epsilon squared using
numbers of
only poly logarithmic bit length
okay so you might find this surprising
because people
run eye again matlab all the time but
ike is actually just a heuristic it's
not a proven algorithm and there are
examples where it doesn't work
matlab can actually literally say i
can't diagonalize this matrix
and you might also be surprised because
you might think that diagonalization is
an n cubed operation well it is n cubed
for hermitian matrices so there's a
famous result
in the from the 60s which says that for
hermitian matrices you can solve this
problem and
n cubed log n or epsilon operations with
logarithmic precision
okay so this is kind of a loose end
right we don't actually have an
algorithm for doing this so the other
result i just want to mention is that we
proved the theorem c
last year which is that yeah there is a
randomized algorithm
which actually solves this problem in
nearly matrix multiplication time
okay so it solves the problem and so
omega's exponent of matrix
multiplication
requires n to the omega poly log and n k
over epsilon bit operations
using poly log and n k over epsilon
precision
now k is this parameter from a couple of
slides ago it's eigenv
vector condition number divided by the
minimum eigenvalue gap
okay so
okay this is uh i guess quite an
improvement over the previous results
but it still doesn't solve the problem
written above right the problem written
above is well how do i do it for any
matrix
right this is saying i can solve this
problem in logarithm log
logarithm of a certain condition number
runtime but what about any matrix well
we can okay maybe i'll just briefly say
the the the key ingredient in the proof
of this theorem
is this theorem is based on an algorithm
that's 50 years old
uh the algorithm is based on a certain
newton iteration
and what was missing was a proof that
that newton iteration
still converges uh in finite arithmetic
so what the main contribution of the the
main technical work in the theorem is
the pseudospectral analysis of the
convergence of this mutant iteration
but anyway given this theorem we also
proved this theorem a plus
which is sort of an enhancement of the
theorem a that i gave you earlier which
says
if you give me any matrix and a complex
gaussian matrix
then with high probability the
eigenvector condition number of the
protrude matrix
is bounded by polynomial and n of
epsilon and the minimum eigenvalue gap
is large
it's larger than epsilon n to some
constant okay so the
perturbation is regularizing in two
senses it makes the eigenvalues move
away from each other
and it makes eigenvector condition
numbers small
so given this theorem it's an immediate
corollary that you get a solution to
this problem
in time nearly matrix multiplication
type the algorithm is you just take the
matrix add a gaussian perturbation
that makes this k of a condition number
polynomial
and then you just run this theorem c
algorithm
so okay that's all i want to say that's
a summary of the talk
um we use these three notions of
spectral stability
um the perturbation really improved the
conditioning of these spectral
computations
and there are several open questions one
is the dimension dependence a really
intriguing one is can you de-randomize
this
i have no idea how to de-randomize this
i still don't know how to find a
perturbation e with these properties
without using randomness
so anyway that's it
any questions okay great um
thank you nico um
so people have questions we
we are out of time but we have a long
break so if people have questions please
go ahead
i have a question so so i was actually
curious about the last um
part that you wrote the very last
sentence that you wrote about bernoulli
do you actually expect it to be better
or do you expect that the gaussian will
actually give you the best
absolute best um
i'm natural algorithm estimate for for
regularization
uh i don't expect the bernoulli to be
better
um i i mean it's
uh i don't have i don't have any
mechanism in mind that would make the
bernoulli better
uh the bernoulli is sort of a first step
towards
uh maybe being able to analyze sparse
random matrices which would have
applications
um so it's mostly a technical challenge
that
like all the arguments uh okay at least
the arguments i presented in our papers
use these limiting arguments
as epsilon goes to zero that breaks for
bernoulli
the paper of uh jan sai and sony i think
might be more
amenable to doing something without
because they don't actually take a limit
they just said epsilon to be like two to
the minus n or something
there is some bottleneck in the current
techniques that
really requires absolutely continuous
density
so i'd like to i really want to
understand whether that's really needed
um any other questions
um yeah like you were just talking about
this
uh this spillman and tank result that
you used um
in a recent archive paper people are
looking at like
what happens if you add like sparse
gaussian noise
do you think that your results could
like
basically use this and extend to to that
case as well where
you have sparse knives or like low
low rank noise yeah so so it's very
possible i mean
the key thing you need at a technical
level to prove this kind of result by
this technique
is you need a tail estimate with a
correct dependence on epsilon
so you need to prove that this
probability so let's do complex
for now um uh
you need to prove that this probability
is less than epsilon squared
because you need to take this limit
divided by epsilon squared so if you can
do that for let's say
sparse gaussian then i mean yeah that's
the technical problem we need to solve
it's a different difficulty from the
bernoulli case where in bernoulli you
can't take the limit at all so you need
to do something else
but yeah okay thanks
okay um in the theorem c where is the
randomization coming from
so in theorem so i didn't tell you what
theorem c is
what the algorithm is so it's an
algorithm called spectral bisection it's
a divide and conquer algorithm
which works by recursively computing
spectral projectors onto
uh subspaces that account for roughly
half the spectrum
now to do that the rand one thing you
need to do is you need to find a line in
the complex plane
that divides the eigenvalues roughly in
half
and the randomness is only used in that
so i'm pretty sure you can de-randomize
it like
right we haven't done it yet so i didn't
say that but crmc barely uses randomness
it's just used in doing binary search
with random offsets
okay um so
i guess we meet again at uh two o'clock
west coast time um you can
you kill well we can stay for a few more
minutes if people have
any questions you want to discuss but
otherwise thanks again
thanks